thank you
[Applause]
I hurt my hand oh yes happy
happy Monday everybody
you know and happy pride month yeah yeah
thank you although it already seems like
a year
maybe it's because all we talk about for
the other 11 months is pride month I'm
seeing rainbows everywhere but the sky
so let's talk about war
well would you rather we do trans
all right because that's later in the
show
war is a great topic it's so great in
fact that no one wants to talk about it
it's like bringing up 911 at a baby
shower
yeah that landed
that's proof so we're sending billions
of dollars of weapons to Ukraine but you
wouldn't know it judging by the Press
because when we spend blood and treasure
someone winds up with that treasure what
if Russia bombs a shipment I guess we
can debate that after World War III and
said all we get from the Press are
competing stories about who's winning or
losing and none of it makes sense
and do we care we love to talk about war
in this country when it's the War on
Drugs the war on poverty and so on but
not real war it's a half a world away
both sides talk funny and those slobs on
The View never talk about it
so uh I don't get to make fat jokes
but why is that well war is like a 401k
don't check on it until you cash out
maybe people will care when our army
doesn't have any bullets left
but it's worth pointing out that amidst
this silence there are two men on
opposite sides of politics who are
actually speaking up saying that the
war's got to end the moment you say that
of course though somebody's gonna call
you a Putin puppet
to which you should respond well you're
a puppet of a puppet
and you both have your hands up each
other's asses
a year ago I said that unless you
mitigate the war at the start it becomes
background noise like CNN while you're
waiting at gate C7
someone gets it here's RFK Jr
my own son Connor joined a Foreign
Legion
and fought in the Ukraine and during the
car key of offensive we were told
initially
at the objective was humanitarian in
recent times
President Biden said that one of our
objectives at least
is regime change
of Vladimir Putin Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin
validated President Biden's statement by
saying that our objective in the Ukraine
is to exhaust and degrade the Russian
army that is completely antithetical
to a humanitarian mission
so first I had no idea that his kid went
to fight as part of the Foreign Legion I
thought the legion only existed in Cary
Grant movies
also a Kennedy fighting somewhere else
other than in a bar
just doesn't sound right but that's
pretty damn Brave fighting in Ukraine
considering you might run into Randy
Weingarten
she is there
but it makes RFK the most important
person to listen to unlike most he has
more than skin in the game his own flesh
and blood
although maybe he's biased because he
selfishly doesn't want his son to die
needlessly
so is he a Putin puppet too do you have
the guts to say that to him I don't and
if I don't do you really think someone
like Morning Joe does
so what are the Dems gonna do about RFK
Jr create another Russian hoax to
falsely smear his principled stance you
know it's funny these hoaxes they're
like feds at a trump rally they all
start to look alike
so that's a Democrat running for Prez
here's a Republican
what I think we need to do is end the
Ukraine war on Peaceful terms that yes
do make some major concessions to Russia
including freezing the current lines of
control in a Korean War style promise
disagree really wouldn't want to do
which Ukraine wouldn't want to do and
also a permanent commitment not to allow
Ukraine to enter NATO but in return
Russia has to leave its treaty and its
joint military agreement with China that
better advances American interests and
actually further deters China from going
after Taiwan which I think is a much
higher priority for the United States so
he went
Russia to China maybe he's right all
Paul George and Ringo did attacking John
was push him to Yoko
foreign
so what's this mean when two
oppositional candidates happen to agree
well maybe it's time for the rest of us
to listen to this guy
if I'm president I will have that War
settled in one day 24 hours
I'll meet with zelenski I want Europe to
put up more money we're spending 170
billion dollars for far away land and
they're right next door to that land
right now we want to get that War
settled and I'm not talking about the
money either I'm talking about all the
lives that are being the number of
people being killed and that was far
greater than you hear exactly but that's
nothing new Trump hates War for reasons
all of us do it's a waste of young life
and he thinks America should keep its
f-16s which is really crazy am I right
yet CNN claims that Trump is
politicizing the war well duh you morons
he's running for he's running for
president
it is politics
and he's always been like this except
thinner and less Orange
but he knows the loss of blood and
treasure makes no sense if there's
another way and I think there was the
people in the know saw this war coming
and still it happened and why is that
well you can't speculate her again
you'll be a Putin puppet fact is two
things could be true at once war is a
waste but a war maybe had to be fought
the problem is when a war starts and
gets sponsorship it loses the spotlight
gutfelt gets preempted for a few days
but then people just want to hear
brilliant jokes and Analysis from a hot
stud again
but we all pay for this we don't see the
bill so it keeps going it's like
sponsoring a starving child overseas the
one you saw In Those ads decades ago
we're sponsoring a war that we never
have to see but if you got to pick at
that child that you're sponsoring and
say every six months he's looking more
and more Grim you gotta ask what the
hell are they doing with the money
but there's the other truth that when a
country invades another country you
gotta act against the aggressor even if
you know the outcome outcome is going to
be awful or invasions will continue and
it's not our country it's Ukraine's and
you can't tell them not to fight except
now we're bankrolling the fight and
bodies are piling up like a Cuomo run
nursing home
foreign
joke
and now we may be prolonging the agony
just like people who vote for Gavin
Newsom
so now it feels less like a war and more
like a demolition of an old apartment
building to make way for a casino with
the people still in it
so is that what this election should be
about for us it's about four more years
of a Mindless feeble robot programmed by
the left with no desire to connect our
financial support to thousands of dead
ukrainians ten years ago Joe Biden could
find Ukraine on a map now he can't find
his own front door
so as long as he stays the war goes on
as Lee haplessly sits and waits for
further instructions from his handlers
or the Visiting Angel to come powder his
feet
I'd be happy if a republican beats Biden
to end this war but if a Democrat does
it first awesome because maybe that
shows that Common Sense can cross all
lines even politics and if you want to
fight about it join the Foreign Legion
[Applause]
so big it'll trap Dolphins Fox Business
anchor Lauren Simonetti
foreign
favorite host after the guy from
Applebee's on 42nd in the Times Square
Olive Garden comediate Jeff Dodd
the last person to call her four eyes
still has to wear Orthopedic shirts most
of Kennedy Saves the World podcast
Kennedy
and finally people at the gym ask her
how much it can French press
Fox News contributor Kat Tipp
Kennedy we don't really talk about this
war do we not enough yeah why is that is
it because people it's depressing and
it's easier to look away from it no it's
because people on both sides are really
for it and I look at this and I I listen
to what RFK junior is saying I'm like
where are the hippies because it used to
be the left you know they were the ones
who cornered the real estate on the
anti-war market and then there were a
lot of Republicans who were like well
I've got family members and friends and
we know people who work at this network
who have gone and fought in Endless Wars
and they've seen and felt the cost of
that personally and they don't want that
to continue Ukraine is one of those
places where we could be bankrolling
this for the next 20 years and you know
while I don't agree that Ukraine should
just give back land to Russia I worry
that in 20 years will be broke and
that's what's going to happen exactly
and man have you ever been to Ukraine
Jeff no sir yeah no we're going tonight
a little surprise what
a trip
Victory because you're just destroying
this place where do you I know as a
comedian you probably do not talk about
this but do you have specific people ask
me because you know I'm almost like hey
what do you think about Russia in
Ukraine I'm like if I'm honest I didn't
even know those were different places
you know actually
for both they weren't yeah a long while
ago yes but I uh I don't know I I don't
know it felt like that one guy was going
Hey Hey listen this war we need to get
it over with so we go into this other
War didn't it feel it felt very pro-war
and I like Star Wars I like Cupcake Wars
I like I like War things as long as it's
not actual humans dying yeah so it felt
kind of gross yeah yeah we got also that
guy's what 30 years old or something
37. yeah yeah he's a regular on this
show he was just on a couple very smart
engaging young man unlike you Jeff no I
think I'd have a better shot
well I like that guy he said some stuff
yes
Lauren you look like you look like one
of the most successful dental hygienists
on the planet oh it's all the coffee I
drink no no I'm talking about the white
medical jacket see they cut you down
they cut it up here it looks like a
medical jacket doesn't it
probably shouldn't have pointed that out
I don't like it yeah no no where are you
stand on that you are a you're a
business genius how long do you think
this can go on before we feel it are we
already feeling I I think so it's almost
16 months now right 75 billion plus and
Counting and you know we just heard from
now we're getting ready for the counter
offensive and we just heard from
Ukraine's uh zielinski and and he's
basically saying we're ready but kind of
trying to lessen our hopes be patient
it's going to cost more than we think
it's going to take more time than we
think and
we're we're behind I'm behind Ukraine
because I want them to win but is the
cost worth the Victory and when does the
victory come if he's prepping us that
we're going to be in this for longer and
longer yeah what's the way out what does
Victory look like I don't think anybody
has defined that clearly just yet yeah
it's I and the fact is each both sides
are willing to just keep throwing bodies
at it and Russians have more bodies Kat
you told me in the Green Room that you
love a good War I knew you were going to
go that direction
[Laughter]
where do you I mean we know where you
stand exactly yeah but like like Kennedy
said I mean both sides they agree that
this is good and you're not really
allowed to have another opinion even to
the point where when it came out that
the government was shock or lying to us
about this one too people a lot of the
anger was like Hey we're not supposed to
know that yeah
hello respect yourself a little
um and I mean there's been really no
major consequences for us for uh being
involved in this but we shouldn't just
assume that that means that there never
will be and in fact the longer we stay
involved and the more involved we get
that actually Rises the odds of that so
I think that the fact that we're even
talking about it is good because
everyone just kind of accepted it and
then it will just probably go on forever
and ever just like we've seen with so
many of those words yeah we'll do they
will do one monologue every six months
okay and then we'll move on actually
probably more than anywhere else yeah
ratio 16 months is a year and four
months
you know what people didn't think you
could handle this exactly but you're
naming the war day it's like it's a baby
or something
24th 2022.
I remember because it was a terrible
week and then we were we were in Texas
yeah Texas and they canceled all
ourselves but oh I have a theory I have
a kind of I have a weird Theory the real
if Trump was super gung-ho about Ukraine
all the people that were were um gung-ho
now wouldn't be because Trump would be
for it absolutely I think that and then
I also think that if RFK gets traction
on this they're going to pull a Russian
collusion background thing on him they
did to Trump so he disappeared like they
want to make sure that his views will be
compromised yeah so what what they have
to hope is that Trump comes out full
bore for the war that's that's the
anti-war people have to hope because
that's the only way the media and the
establishment will then be against the
war you got it it is fresh it is fresh
to see a Kennedy in politics
finally just don't let them Drive okay
I just praised him
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else